donc c'est un enfant qui a de l'oxygène
qui est directement branché au niveau de
sa trachéotomie c'est plutôt du soin de
confort pour Jodel 8 ans le nettoyage de
sa trachée est quotidien cet enfant vit
au centre pédiatrique des côtes au loge
en Josas cette structure accueille 58
enfants malades dont une quinzaine sont
polyhandicapés comme je tel ses parents
viennent plusieurs fois par semaine de
Montreuil pour être auprès de lui
Joda c'est une grossesse qui a été
normale pendant les échographies tout et
tout on n'a jamais su que il avait une
malformation c'est le jour de sa
naissance je crois le lendemain le même
jour il a fait une réaction anormale
quand on lui donnait le lait ça passait
par ses narines tout ça il est tout fait
il n'arrivait pas à prendre le lait les
médecins lui diagnostic une laryngo
traquée aux Malassis sévère une
malformation lui empêchant une
oxygénation suffisante des poumons à
l'âge de 6 mois il arrive dans ce centre
pédiatrique pendant les premières années
de Jodel notre château était notre
maison
je vivais au château avec Jodel on avait
une on avait une chambre donc l'équipe
soignante était devenue notre famille
c'était devenu notre quotidien c'était
notre maison le château son lourd
handicap l'empêche de pouvoir rentrer au
domicile auprès de ces trois frères les
parents ont fait une demande pour
obtenir un logement plus grand et plus
proche l'espoir de pouvoir accueillir
Joëlle prochainement
[Musique]
chaque semaine des ateliers d'éveil
musical sont organisés au centre pour
les enfants objectifs pour Jodel essayer
de stimuler ses sens autour de divers
instruments un moment d'échange et de
partage avec sa famille vu maintenant
que on sait qu'il entend et que il
réagit beaucoup par elles sont donc on
cherche tout ce qui est musical tout ce
qui fait des paroles voilà ça fait un
petit moment d'échanger avec lui parfois
il va s'ouvrir parfois il va suivre du
regard et puis parfois non même il va
même s'endormir donc non on cherche à
faire c'est tout simplement essayer
d'éveiller un peu les enfants et puis
apporter un peu de joie si on peut si on
les stimule pas d'une quelconque façon
et qu'on n'arrive pas à échanger on peut
vite créer de la détresse chez ses
enfants le centre aimerait développer un
système de communication permettant à
Joël d'exprimer ses envies grâce à la
reconnaissance
oculaire d'une tablette le projet estimé
à 100.000 euros est à la recherche de
donateur
je serai là
toujours pour toi